Pharma is corporate health care and I
don't believe that health care should be
a for-profit business and unfortunately
with pharma it totally is like this
bosal that pill that aids patients
needed and this bosal raises the price
from $12 a pill to what was it nine
hundred dollars or something ridiculous
well there you've got an example of
private sector coming in and making
everything for profit always remember
that there's a difference and this is
for the people out there that for these
like CEOs like Trump that run there's a
difference between government and a
corporation corporations are for profit
that is all there for turning out profit
for the for the shareholders government
is to provide services and that's a
different ballgame providing services to
being for-profit so you cannot run them
the same way people are say Oh run it
like a private corporation no private
corporations are for-profit and that's
what you're seeing in the healthcare
industry today it's being run for-profit
and I don't think people's health should
be run for profit certainly people that
work in the industry should earn a
living no one's denying that but when
you read about the heads of these health
care's
making what 40 million a year stock
options to where they're you have so
much money they couldn't spend it all
all at the sake of our health health
should not be for profit if you're sick
in a country like ours it's simple you
should have the ability to go see a
doctor everybody in this country
deserves the same health care that
congressmen get how's that whatever
congressman gets you and I deserve the
same thing they should be no better or
no worse than us
after all don't they work for us or
aren't they supposed to we're the boss
they're the employee all you see on
daytime television and I love it tell
your doctor about this drug well let me
steal from Bill Maher if I'm will for a
moment if you're telling your doctor
what you need your doctor's not a doctor
he's a dealer he should be telling you
what you need he's the doctor so why do
they do ads on TV telling you to take
these drugs and the point is yes they do
control our entire healthcare system
today the pure libertarians almost an
anarchist
I've butted heads with them at times and
and and they believe there's some of
them that there's no role of government
at all and I've kind of said come on in
a civilized society you've got to have
some type of entity that in that that
performs fairness within society you'd
have anarchy if you don't have in a
civil society if you don't have some
form of control of the people so I
understand the libertarian viewpoint
enough but I'm also a realist you know
you're not gonna live in Utopia
that's impossible we're human beings we
make mistakes we're not gods
we're humans
you